- On m'a demandé plusieurs fois
de faire des visites guidées
du 11 septembre. J'ai refusé
pendant longtemps parce que
je ne voulais pas en parler.
- Guide touristique...
- C'est la tour numéro 1.
- ... et new-yorkais depuis
des décennies, Benoît Gendron
a longtemps évité dans le
quartier de Lower Manhattan où
s'élevaient les tours jumelles
du World Trade Center.
- Quand on m'a convaincu
de venir faire la visite guidée,
bien, je me suis rendu compte
que ça m'a aidé à reconnecter
avec ces événements-là, à ne pas
les éviter et à regarder, aller
au-delà du premier avion,
du deuxième avion,
de l'effondrement, d'enlever
cette tristesse. C'est celle
qui s'est effondrée.
- L'immense tristesse causée
par l'attentat qui a tué presque
3000 personnes a fait place
à un autre sentiment.
- Ça évoque la guérison,
pour moi.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Quand l'édifice nord s'est
effondré, il y a eu
un raz-de-marée de débris
qui défilaient à toute vitesse
vers l'église.
- Benoît Gendron commençait
ses tours guidés devant
cette chapelle, déjà réputée
pour avoir survécu à
des incendies parce qu'elle a
échappé au pire il y a 20 ans.
- Derrière, un carreau d'une
fenêtre a été brisé et c'est
tout, et c'est tout! Un seul
carreau d'une fenêtre!
- Sur ce grilles, on pouvait
lire des messages laissés entre
autres par des parents,
des enfants, des frères,
des soeurs, désespérés, sans
nouvelles de leurs proches.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On parlait du trou béant, moi
je l'ai jamais vu, comme la
plupart des New-yorkais d'abord
parce que de façon subconsciente
on évitait le quartier.
- Ce quartier de la haute
finance, incarnation
du capitalisme, qui en a fait
une cible de choix pour
les terroristes, est devenue
un symbole de mort
le 11 septembre 2001.
- La plupart des gens ne
le voit pas comme lieu
de sépulture. Il le voir
comme un mémorial.
- L'eau représente nos larmes.
- En souvenir des victimes, on
peut lire leur nom autour
des deux bassins construits sur
les lieux des tours jumelles.
- Si vous apercevez une rose
blanche, insérée dans un nom,
c'est pour nous dire
qu'aujourd'hui aurait été
l'anniversaire de naissance
de cette personne.
- Vous savez, il y a 6 millions
de personnes par années
qui viennent visiter.
- Un devoir de mémoire pour
une tragédie que les moins
de 20 ans ne peuvent
pas connaître.
- On voit beaucoup d'ados
avec leur téléphone, qui font
des selfies avec les grands...
les grands sourires au-dessus
des piscines, moi ça me dérange,
mais on ne peut pas leur
en vouloir. Ils n'étaient
pas là. Ils ne savent pas
ce que c'est.
Ils ont besoin d'être éduqués.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Cet arbre, retrouvé vivant
mais fortement endommagé sous
les débris de Ground 0,
est présenté comme
un exemple de résilience.
- C'est la seule chose qui
a survécu des événements
du 11 septembre.
- Des survivants participent
à l'occasion au tour guidé
de Benoît Gendron, il sent chez
les visiteurs un besoin
de boucler la boucle.
- Il se sentent obligés de me
dire ce qu'ils ont fait, eux,
le 11 septembre et comment
ils l'ont vécu, j'ai jamais ça
quand je fais la Statue de
la Liberté, j'ai jamais ça quand
je fais (inaudible), j'ai jamais
ça quand je fais Wall Street,
mais je l'ai ici. C'est comme
un lieu où tout le monde vient
pour communier et puis
on s'échange des histoires.
- La reconstruction se poursuit
sur le site qui a recommencé
à vivre sous une nouvelle forme
et de nouveaux visages avec
une variété d'entreprises
qui ont choisi de s'installer
dans cette tour surnommée
"Freedom Tower".
- Ça ne m'a jamais effleuré
l'idée. Jamais effleuré l'idée.
- Qu'est-ce qu'il ne vous
a jamais effleuré l'idée?
- De partir de New York.
- Parce qu'il tenait a
participer à la renaissance
de la grosse pomme dont
les résidents ont changé,
eux aussi dit-il.
- Énormément différents.
Je fais le test des fois avec
les gens qui viennent à
la visite guidée, je leur
demande : "Combien d'entre vous
sont venus à New York avant
le 11 septembre? C'était quoi
votre impression
des New-yorkais?" "Ah! Bien,
ils sont 'ruffs', ils sont
'toffs', ils vous parlent pas,
ils sont bla bla bla". Je dis :
"Ok. Et maintenant? C'est quoi
votre réaction face à tous
ces différents,
ils sont gentils?"
- En ce 20e anniversaire
des attentats, qui ont endeuillé
la ville et les États-Unis,
le New-yorkais d'adoption
résume ainsi ce qui lui inspire
le site emblématique.
- C'est un état d'âme.
C'est vraiment...
C'est